ich glaube das hat's wirklich noch nicht
gegeben da gibt's einen Künstler der
kündigt sein Album an das hat einen
Titel und da gibt's einen anderen dessen
Album kommt vorher raus und der benennt
das mal eben so um dass es fast so heißt
wie das Album des anderen also es ist
die Rede von kollega und sein Album wird
jetzt Boss Aura heißen und cool Savage
der hat sein Album Aura genan was aber
später im November erst rauskommt hey
ist das jetzt eine besonders
hinterhältige Art cool Savage auf die
Palme zu bringen oder wirklich nur
Zufall das könn jetzt in den Kommentaren
diskutieren und hier der originaloton
von kollega wo es im Interview ankündigt
und wenn er dran bleiben wollt das der
ganze Interview gibt den N nichtst also
abonnieren hier oben drücken dann
verpasst er nichts von kollega und
vielen anderen pomis auf
klicksom wie wird jetzt heißen ja das
definitive letzte also der letzte Titel
des Albums ist jetzt Bossaura okay und
der Titel ist natürlich auch ganz klar
aussagekräftig für meine ganze Karriere
Boss ich habe meine Karriere stets von
der Bossaura umgeben so durchgezogen ich
meine seit F F oder se Jahren war ich
mit der Bossaura einfach am Start ja und
die Leute haben es gecheckt und haben
sich dran gewöhnt und jetzt ist es
soweit um das auch mal jetzt offiziell
zu manifestieren bossaurer ist der Titel
des neuen Albums 14.10 kommt es raus
aber gibt ja nicht noch ein anderen
Grund für weil ich weiß gibt ja noch so
ein Album was so ähnlich heißt ja das
ist Zufall das ist ein Titel den habe
ich schon vor 5 Jahren gerappt im ersten
dis Track gegen separate wie hieß noch
mal ein guter Tag zum Sterben genau ich
habe die Bossaura Note du nur die
kockauge Aura wie eine Moskauer
habe ich den Begriff geprägt schon seit
5 Jahren gibt's den das ist es ist es
ist irrelevanter jetzt drüber zu reden
dass das irgendwie ist von Kur wassch
blablabla also es ist Quatsch ja ist
Zufall aber der Zufall wird ja
wahrscheinlich Z für Diskussion sorgen
oder ja das ist halt das Ding sorgt
immer für Diskussionen dann aber ganz
ehrlich ich bin ehrlicher Mensch es war
jetzt nicht irgendwie um svst da zu
dissen oder oder irgendwie dann
Konkurrenzkampf wer die krassere Aura
hat oder so das ist alles Quatsch aber
voher hieß es doch anders wie das war
der Arbeitstitel hi Flex Rock Roll ja
aber das war das er das war das erste
Lied was ich gemacht habe für das Album
das hie Flex Lutz Rock and Roll das war
der erste Song halt den ich aufgenommen
habe und ich hatte noch keinen Titel ich
habe noch überlegt und habe gesagt okay
machen wir erstmal Arbeitstitel Flex
Latz Rock and Roll weil das einfach der
erste Track war so und dann habe ich
jetzt im Nachhinein Hal die ganzen
anderen Tracks gemacht und dann habe ich
auch ein Track gemacht der hieß
Bossaura der wird jetzt auch ich glaube
wenn das Interview online ist wird er
schon bekannt sein der Track also ihr
wisst Bescheid Freunde Boss auch
natürlich alles zfickt ja klar Battle
Rap mal wieder neu definiert neu
revolutioniert
und dementsprechend natürlich muss das
Album Bossaura heißen klar Frage gehört
muss das sein oder gehört das dazu dass
man auch dann immer ich sag mal die
Gelegenheit sucht der
Konfrontation ich wie gesagt ich weiß
jetzt gar nicht warum Du immer noch von
Konfrontation redest ich habe dir ja
gesagt es ist nicht wegen Konfrontation
es ist ein
Zufall ja ich wollte das Album
eigentlich schon vor zwei Jahren Album
namens Bossaura machen ich habe da nur
Mixtapes gedopppt und jetzt ist halt
seit dass ich ein Album mache und jetzt
heißt es Bossaura kannst genauso gut
sagen warum will Kur jetzt sein Album
auchnennen will er auf
Konfrontationskurs gehen mit dem Boss
aber ich glau ja gut aber ich glaube das
glaubt ja keiner oder ist mir scheißegal
ich weiß meinwegen sollen die Leute auch
denken dass ich auf Konfrontationskurs
gehen will ist mir doch scheißegal mein
Album heißt so und ich aus Micky Maus
Nikolaus
okay